>> CHRIS: IT'S TIME FOR "FOX AND
THE FRIEND HOUSE."
"FOX AND THE FRIEND HOUSE."
ON A RECENT EPISODE OF "FOX AND
FRIENDS,"
THE FRIENDS SHARED SOME TIPS ON
HOW TO APPEAR TOLERANT ON
FACEBOOK. I WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR: NOT HOW TO BE
TOLERANT, BUT HOW TO APPEAR
TOLERANT.
FIRSTLY, THE 3F'S:
"KEEP POLITICAL POSTS TO FACTS,
FIGURES AND FUNNY!"
TIP TWO:
"IF A FRIEND CROSSES THE LINE,
UNFOLLOW THEM."
AND FINALLY, I [BLEEP] YOU NOT:
"JOIN A CLOSED FACEBOOK GROUP
DEDICATED TO YOUR POINT OF
VIEW."
YOU KNOW, LIKE "FOX AND
FRIENDS"!
COMEDIANS, I'M SURE THEY WERE
ONLY SCRATCHING THE SURFACE OF
THEIR TOLERANCE TIPS.
WHAT ARE SOME OTHER FOX &
FRIENDS FACEBOOK TOLERANCE TIPS?
IN 60 SECONDS AND BEGIN.
>> FOLLOW A BIG SCARY BLACK GUY
ON TWITTER.
SEE HOW HE LIKES IT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
>> JUST WRITE THE WORD "FLAGS"
WE'LL KNOW THE "L" IS SILENT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ANNIE.
>> YOUR POSTS ARE NOT FETUSES.
IT'S OKAY TO ABORT THEM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DAN.
>> REFER TO BITCHES AS "WOMEN."
CHRIS: POINTS.
GREG.
>> MAKE SURE YOU'RE AROUND LIKE
MINDED PEOPLE BEFORE REFERRING
TO THE HOLOCAUST WITH AIR
QUOTES.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> POST ALL THE RIFLE PICS
YOU WANT. THERE IS NO SUCH THING
AS GUN PHOTO CONTROL.